le général dominique traque ans d'un
chef de mission militaire française à
l'onu bonsoir général franco merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors plus de bureaux liaison le message
de la corée du nord est extrêmement
clair ce bureau c'était avant tout un
symbole
oui c'était un symbole il n'existait pas
depuis très très longtemps et ça faisait
partie de l'amélioration des relations
entre la corée du nord et la corée du
sud est donc pour l'instant on s'attaque
aux symboles oui tout à fait alors ça
veut dire quoi
c'est un symbole donc ce n'est pas si
grave simple coup de pression ou peuvent
les provocations
non je pense qu'il y a deux manoeuvres
dans cette affaire il ya une manoeuvre
qui est la réaction au trac qui ont été
envoyés sur la corée du nord par des
dissidents qui était passé en corée du
sud et donc il faut marquer de façon
très très dur dans les paroles au moins
mais ne pas prendre de mesures
dramatiques
l'armée par ailleurs a indiqué qu'elle
était prête pour la guerre ça c'est le
tout ce qui est visible ce qui est moins
visible c'est que pour une fois c'est la
soeur du leader qui a parlé et non pas
le leader
et donc je pense qu'il ya une montée en
puissance la de la soeur cadette qui est
quelqu'un qui apparemment a pris
beaucoup de place dans le régime
effectivement la sarre qui a des propos
d'ailleurs assez belliqueux
pourquoi on peut se poser la question
cette stratégie de pyongyang qui
cherchent tout de même convenu mais les
relations entre les deux corées qu'elle
est l'arrière pensée s'il y en a une on
baissé de se placer alors sur les deux
plans de marc et qu'elle n'accepte pas
la propagande qui est fait par le sud
vers le nord
ça c'est un premier point qui est
constant dans la république coréenne
populaire coréenne est la deuxième point
c'est que pour être un leader en corée
il faut être très martial très va-t-en
guerre et c'est un peu le langage de la
soeur actuellement pour marquer qu'elle
prend sa place dans la hiérarchie auprès
du leader
alors pourquoi maintenant ces tensions
entre les deux corées qu'elle est
le contexte au global alors écoutez il
faudrait vraiment rentrer à l'intérieur
du système et ce qui est un petit peu
compliqué vous en douter mais lors de la
crise du corona virus qui a touché un
petit peu la corée aussi on a beaucoup
parlé de maladies qu'avait le leader et
en particulier qu'il avait été opéré
alors tout de suite après on a montré
des images pour montrer que ce n'était
pas vrai mais on se doute qu'il n'est
pas en très bonne santé et donc il ya
peut-être une manoeuvre qui consiste à
faire monter en premier plan quelqu'un
qui pourrait lui succéder s'il y avait
un problème
ça veut dire que effectivement la soeur
de kim jong-un pourrait justement être
cette personne qui succéderait oui on le
dit depuis longtemps que c'est quelqu'un
de très influent souvenez-vous les
rencontres elle était présente à côté de
son frère
donc ça c'était un jeu des gestes
importants mais là elle apparaît seul
donc ça veut dire qu'elle grimpe encore
un cran dans cette hiérarchie est cette
capacité de lancer des messages
au nom du pays alors il ya eu des
réactions à ces tensions à washington
qui exhorte pyongyang notamment éviter
de nouveaux actes contre-productif
quel peut être le rôle justement des
états étrangers notamment des états unis
dans cette affaire on précise que les
négociations notamment sur le nucléaire
n'ont pas encore abouti
vous faites bien de le préciser parce
qu'à part les shows du présidentmd
simple il ya pas grand chose avec la
corée du nord
ceux qui ont vraiment un impact c'est
naturellement la chine et je ne pense
pas que ce que peut dire le pré le
gouvernement américain puisse avoir un
impact sur la corée du nord
est ce que peut dire l'union européenne
qui s'est aussi exprimée en ce sens
qu'il fallait arrêter les provocations
non mais toutes ces déclarations sont
les bienvenus mais je ne suis pas
persuadé que c'est un impact sur le
gouvernement
si ce n'est que ça montre l'importance
que nous accordons aux réactions de ce
gouvernement dictatorial
alors on précise tout de même un 2003
quand je m'adresse aux militaires les
deux corées sont toujours techniquement
en guerre depuis le messti oui bien sûr
ils sont techniquement en guerre est
d'ailleurs une des déclarations de
l'armée n'était que l aller fortifier la
ligne de démarcation alors que c'est
pti avait été neutralisée depuis
quelques temps donc c'est de revenir à
un niveau de confrontation boîte on
crame clairement une escalade ces
prochains temps non je crois qu'il va y
avoir des démonstrations quel type de
démonstration un tir de missile quelque
chose comme ça mais je ne pense pas que
ça puisse aller à une confrontation
le gouvernement du nord n'y a pas
intérêt merci mission militaire
française à l'onu d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ô